well not it has to be set for the first
time Nigel Farage has announced his
official return to the brexit fray this
morning right in the Daily Telegraph the
former leader of you Kip says it will be
negligent to stand by and watch mp's
wreck Britain's bid to leave the
European Union and he joins me now
welcome good morning Nigel Farage I mean
what you're saying is you're preparing
to stand in the European elections but
actually we're not going to be having
any European like all's country there
were lots of things we weren't gonna
happen that have happened over the
course of the last two years the
position had it is very simple you know
my new year's resolution was to hope for
the best but prepare for the worst the
best of course is that 498 MPs voted for
article 50 which says we negotiate their
withdrawal agreement but if that doesn't
go through we leave on WTO terms I mean
that is the law of the land right now if
that holds I will be delighted because
we'll be out and you know what will be
an independent self-governing nation
okay was what it was about but my fear
is that our political establishment
including our prime minister because you
know when she spoke at Florence she
talked about this deep and special
partnership so I think that I fear that
the House of Commons is going to
effectively overturn that brexit and to
me the most likely outcome of all of
this is an extension of article 50 if
article 50 gets extended for more than
three months we will be contesting the
European election but no one is saying
that's going to happen in fact there are
ways as you well know because you'll
remember the European Parliament of
getting round this and simply rolling
over your membership or whatever well
you're saying you think it's quite
likely now that we're going to have
European election
it's point firstly it's possible we get
European elections and secondly you know
it's the worst case scenario but there
could be another referendum and what I
do know is that the remain side are
well-funded well-organized they're
getting ready for a second referendum it
would be negligent of the Euroskeptics
not to do so okay now the next question
is you're not a member of you clip
anymore I know I'm not and the way you
get elected is by being on a list party
list so if you're serious about getting
real
to the European Parliament you're gonna
have to find a party to stand for he's
absolutely right and that is work in
progress so you'll be rejoining UK I
think that's now impossible sadly I
think new cube has gone down a route
that makes it unsolvable so now it'll
have to be a new vehicle and that is
working progress and what what would it
be called well as I say that's working
protein there are lots of little parties
out there that one could sort of pick up
and use right now the constant new
applications going in now I'm working on
it I mean there will be a vehicle ready
my point is this you know if suddenly
this was sprung upon us yeah if a
European election was sprung upon us or
if a second referendum were sprung upon
us if we weren't ready we've been a very
bad you you are a patriot I think you'd
see yourself as a patriot I would and
dad's army found another thing now just
let me encourage you that if we're not
ready to leave
what on earth is wrong in delaying for a
few months and that may well become the
argument you know that may well become
the argument I personally think is a
total failure of government that during
two and a half years we've not got
ourselves ready to leave we're not fit
and proper to do it I don't want the
extension of article 50 because I fear
that once you kick the can down the road
once you do it again and the second
referendum comes into that gap look I
was you'd actually quite like to carry
on being a member the European I mean it
gives you know I've been there for 20
years
and I'll be very happy not to go back of
look Adam I want us to leave the
European Union become an independent
country and then my role in politics is
over this is what I came into it to do
now I fear yeah we're on the verge of it
being betrayed I'm not going to stand by
and watch this I do want to ask you
about that because you know one of the
reasons why he left you Kip it was
because of it's moving closer to Tommy
Robinson yeah a video we've had those
very nice tea incidents outside
Parliament's involved I've been involved
in some kind of MPs and other yeah it's
in their risk if you run around talking
about betrayal and all the rest of it
that you are saying to unsavory elements
you know get stirred up get on the
streets know what I mean oh that's
exactly the reason for getting a
political party ready rather than people
going out onto the streets and being var
let's do it democratically through a
political party and you know whatever
criticisms were made of me in all the
years running and leading you care we
never allowed that violent fringe to
ever be a part of it and this is why
democracy works democracy works because
it gives you it gives you a mechanism
it's a let off steam without resorting
device so you would never say to people
take to the streets I would say to
people peaceful protest is absolutely
fine but anything beyond that is just
plain wrong if Parliament takes control
as people are saying and works through
the options and comes out with something
which takes Britain out of the political
structures of the European Union
including them sorry the European
Parliament that surely would be
democracy in action as well wouldn't it
well I think what's frustrating Adam is
this you know every single leading
player on both the leave and remains
side in that referendum said a vote to
leave means we are leaving the single
market and the customs unit it could not
have been clearer and what I see with
these cross party talks that are now
going on is a move towards well they
talk about the Norway model but actually
what's being discussed here is worse
than Norway because it wouldn't just be
single market rules it would be customs
union membership as well
we'd be Norway without the fish so that
is certainly not what people voted for
and you know people argue what did what
did the brexit vote mean it meant
leaving the political structure argument
there is always people didn't vote to be
poor and we heard about the exchange
rate map barriers they were wrong
reading with our biggest trading
partners which is what coming out knows
you know putting up barriers we're
bringing down across the world actually
make people poorer wouldn't it know
we're going to make food cheaper we got
to make clothes cheaper we're going to
re-engage with the Commonwealth and many
other parts of the world that we've
effectively turned our backs on we will
be a freer trading Britain outside this
protectionist club with its added air of
authoritarianism
I'm absolutely certain we are doing the
right thing it's just that Parliament
doesn't quite believe in it
not if I think very much indeed for
joining us well let's get the thoughts
now of the MP Westminster MP
Conservative MP Shailesh vara you're
putting out or supporting a new thing
called a better deal a better future for
Britain and its relations with Europe is
there much you disagree with that
knowledge or Farage's actually I have to
say I agree with much of what Nigel said
and I think it's important that we
recognise seventeen point four million
people voted in the biggest Democratic
exercise in our country's history and it
was made absolutely clear as Nigel says
by all the leaders of the referendum
pain that this was a one-off and the
decision would be binding and to the
remain as I would say that their own
leaders the then Prime Minister David
Cameron former Prime Minister's Tony
Blair
John Major Nick Clegg and it's all out
there on social media they can see the
video clips of the interviews that you
and others did of these people they said
the results of this referendum must be
binding and I think that I'm glad to say
that because legally it wasn't no no
they said it because it was true and
they meant it but sadly they didn't it
from their point of view they didn't
expect to lose and it would be absurd if
we now had a second referendum because
at what point do we stop having
referendums if the other side were to
win this time does it become best of
three best of five now John is looking
for a party and sounds like he'd fit
into your Conservative Party well we
have certain rules of regulations and I
happy to put Nigel in the right
direction and and he's a seasoned
politician and you know if he fulfils
our criteria would be happy to have him
on board
i David mrs. Mays Conservative Party
would have me but maybe a Conservative
Party that was led by somebody who was a
committed brexit ear Boris Johnson's
making a bid today would you like to be
in Boris Johnson's concern you know I
would just like to see a conservative
party led by somebody who really
believed in Britain III think it is
important national is right there that
we need to believe in Britain we need to
believe in the United Kim this deal that
we've got on the table right now Adam
has been negotiated on the basis of fear
people who can't see beyond Europe if
you look at all the economic data the
economic progress is going to be in the
countries outside the EU in the decades
ahead yes but its economic progress from
a much smaller base of our economic
relationships with them so you know
actually a few percentage points in art
in relation or trade with Europe and
worth a lot more than actually a
doubling in our trade with some of these
well know if we stay locked in this
unending backstop and the customs union
we will be tied to EU rules and
regulations but if we freed from that
then we can do free trade deals with
China India where you say can or could I
mean the reality we well the we could do
and we could do its success reality is
if we leave without a and agreement will
actually be leaving a lot of current
trade deals with a lot of these
countries that you say you want to do
trade deals which it be wholly it would
be very easy to do deals with these
people because at the moment they eat
the EU has deals with with a lot of
these countries and we would be happy to
look at those views again and I can tell
you this the deals that the UK would
make with these premises are can be
hugely diplomacy I can see the
aspiration that you have but I've been
talking to people like you and I've been
talking to people from other countries
for two years now and I've said okay
where are these great fantastic deals
that are going to be good for a bridge
economy and no one has been able to
point to any firm Anita's own limited I
have been talking to people as well from
other countries Nani you countries and
they are saying if you lock yourselves
into the customs union whereby the
tariff rules are made by the EU you are
going to make it difficult for
yourselves and Woody Johnson the
ambassador of the USA has said if the
United Kingdom is stuck in the customs
union it'll be difficult to form a big
deal where you have extremely good
trading relation we can Germany which is
a member of the European Union has very
good trading relations with a lot of
these countries that you say we want you
mentioned USA let me just say the USA
trades with the EU on wgo rules library
about WTO terms have almost no countries
that actually trade on WTO terms they
all have sides the Commons library has
said that there are countries such as
the USA Argentina China Australia which
we trade protocols right we may have and
I will send you the research from house
combat you will read it out on the
saying you're saying of course we report
that it is a chimera to say that most of
the world trades on WTO terms they do
not Australia trades with the EU on WTO
rules the Prime Minister Prime Minister
of Australia has said that are straight
hundred billion u.s. side pipes another
hundred billion Australian dollars rules
are the basis for what we have a good
trading relationship with the USA which
indeed we do based on WTO terms yes with
add-ons over time of course
why is everybody terrified of trading
with the European Union on WTO turn
what's the problem here because we're
that close to here I mean then we could
at the unlikely thing we could apply
haneda
we could apply to a WTO example Canada
does not trade with the US on Canada
terms because it's its neighbor and the
extent of its economic involvement is
much greater yes as is our economic
involvement for quite obvious
geographical reasons so the analogy is
in fact to have a Canada style
relationship with the EU
similar to what Canada has with the US
and that's not permitted to get on you
tier turn but let's look at the big
picture Adam let let 10 years ago 50
percent of our overseas trade was with
Europe that figure is now about 38
percent let's not split hairs let's look
at the global trip I'm not freaking out
let's look at the global trends you know
the point about brexit is we are looking
ahead we're not looking backwards
we look into the world as it goes
forward it's aspirational you're walking
away from what you've got onto an
aspiration which you might be right to
say as far as the business community is
concerned there is a rich irony here is
that once we accept that there'll be
short-term difficulty if we were to go
out and WTO rules the irony is that the
business community no self-respecting
businesswoman or man would go into
negotiation and tell the other side I'm
taking no deal off the table yet the
United Kingdom let me finish please the
United Kingdom is engaged in the biggest
trade deal biggest business deal of our
history and yet the business community
is asking us to do precisely what they
wouldn't do and you need to have no deal
on the table because it makes sure that
we get a better deal nobody really wants
to have no policy will get a better deal
because the other side that fears No
Deal as much as we do and with ten weeks
to go it's a bit late to start talking
games actually go to the practice we
administer the leader of your party and
your government has been negotiating for
two and a half years and actually they
came to an agreement which has just been
rejected by the House of Commons so to
now start talking about the brilliant
way in which we're going to negotiate
with the European Union I mean yeah the
truth is the year you can do anything in
the European Union has a set of rules
and basically for us the decision is at
what level we get one thing that changes
all of this is that at the moment we
have full regulatory alignment and I
think the real frustration is that this
Prime Minister never sought a genuine
free trade agreement and the way you get
a genuine free trade agreement is you
announced your leaving on WTO terms
there'll be overnight blind panic in
failure of negotiation by Theresa May
who did not strike out on a clear path
after decades are trying to opt out of
parts of the European Union on leaving
she tried to opt us back into it I think
it is never too late we've got 10 weeks
to go where there's a political will
anything and everything can be achieved
the point is we need to stand up
tell that ye you that we are prepared to
walk out on a no deal basis I don't want
to walk out no dealer basis but the fact
is all those scare stories planes won't
fly large road gang all of that is
slowly beginning to uh none of those
deals have been done yet yeah Brussels
has said that we will allow our lorries
to go into the EU and that so long as we
allow their launch to come here until
the end of em I've displayed no no all
of these scarce whereas Mike rightly
said they've seen it at the time of the
RM time of the the referendum yeah at
the time of Europe we had all these
scarce or okay none of the material ask
you one very simple question even if we
accept everything you're saying that all
these side deals going to be in place
and all that nonetheless it's a massive
expense to prepare for these things so
massive bureaucratic snarl up what is
the gain for the ordinary UK so the
games you talk about his expense if we
go out and No Deal basis we're not
paying that you thirty nine billion
pounds that thirty nine billion dollar
that thirty nine billion pounds can be
using a cushion the economy to help
individuals to help businesses there is
a positive side to this it's not all
doom you know you know very well that
the price of obtaining any of those side
deals is going to be paying up some of
that money but also can we just can we
just remember one other thing this
referendum that we fought and voted on
wasn't about whether Peter Mandelson
things were going to be worse off or I
think we're gonna be better off it was
about do we become an independent
self-governing that's made your argument
it's not been the rise and freedom
that's what this is about if I'd asked
for sovereignty you know they want us to
be able to know how they prepared to be
poorer as the price of sovereignty well
you are going on speculation and project
focus I believe I do not believe that
this great nation of ours fifth
strongest economy in the world head of
the Commonwealth
permanent members of UN Security Council
I do not believe that after a short term
of difficult if you go out on wdsu we
will not be a prosper and that's being
poorer right short term yeah but this is
a deal about our children and our
children's children it is about the
decades ahead it is
about a few months immediately after we
leave we need to put things into context
here this is not just a deal you
honestly therefore say to people how
much pain in the short-term they're
going to face as a result pursuing
though they will be sort short-term
difficulty but I'm also telling them
that there'll be thirty nine billion
pounds to help mitigate some of that
pain of course it would be children they
won't now be able to live and work in
the European Union like they can at the
moment well they could mark that's
completely because we will have there
will be reciprocal rights beyond being
been agreed yet has it actually a lot
has been agreed the main things are the
backstop and the payment of money but
it's a backstop that is the sticking
point to a lot of my colleagues I leave
it there we're going to scrutinize the
research thank you